[موسيقى]
مساء الخير تمر هذه الايام الذكرى السبعين
على انقلاب مصدق في ايران وما هو انقلاب
مصدق ولماذا نتحدث عنه الان انقلاب مصدق
باختصار وتورط المخابرات الامريكيه
والبريطانيه في مؤامره للاطاحه بحكومه
الدكتور محمد مصدق رئيس وزراء ايران
المنتخب ديمقراطيا في اغسطس 1953
هذا الانقلاب ادى لتداعيات خطيره مازلنا
نعيش نتائجها حتى اليوم زرع هذا الانقلاب
ببساطه بذره الشك والكراهيه من جانب
الايرانيين تجاه الامريكان وكانت اوضح
نتائجه القضاء على التجربه الديمقراطيه في
ايران
ودعم تسلط الشاهي الموالي للغرب ما ادى في
نهايه المطاف لقيام الثوره الاسلاميه التي
قادها الخميني في 1979 ولم تقتصر تداعيات
الانقلاب على ايران بل امتدت لمختلف دول
العالم كيف ولماذا الاجابه على هذا السؤال
تقتضي ان نعود بشكل سريع لنعرف ما حدث في
ايران منذ نحو سبعين عاما في سنه 1953
كانت ايران دوله دستوريه ملكيه اي ان
الملك اللي هو اسمه الشاه يملك ولا يحكم
الصلاحيات الحقيقيه في ايدي اعضاء
البرلمان ورئيس الحكومه المنتخب الذي كان
في ذلك الوقت هو الدكتور محمد مصدق
الدكتور مصدق لمن لا يعرفه كان سياسيا
قوميا ومناصرا للديمقراطيه العلمانيه
قوميا يعني انه لم يكن تابعا للشرق او
الغرب
ويضع مصالح ايران اولا وعلمانيا بمعنى انه
كان ضد حكم رجال الدين الذين حكموا بعد
الثوره كانت اهم اولوياته قضيتان واحد
تعزيز نظام الملكيه الدستوريه بانتزاع
المزيد من الصلاحيات من الشاه واعطائها
للبرلمان ورئيس الوزراء استنادا الى دستور
ايران لعام
1906/2 تقليص النفوذ الاجنبي في ايران
وهذا لا يتحقق الا باستعاده السيطره على
صناعه النفط الوطنيه التي كان البريطانيون
يسيطرون عليها منذ اكتشاف النفط في
الاراضي الايرانيه في مطلع القرن العشرين
من خلال شركه النفط الانجلو الايرانيه كان
اسمها كده والتي اصبحت فيما بعد شركه
بريتش بتروليوم او بي بي والتي ما زالت
واحده من اكبر شركات النفط في العالم
في عام 1949 شكل او اسس مصدق حزب الجبهه
الوطنيه وقاده الاحتجاجات ضد شاهي ايران
محمد رضا بهلوي لتحقيق هذين الهدفين اي
هدفين تقليل صلاحيات الشاه وتاميم البترول
صناعه البترول الايرانيه
ونجح مصدق مع اساس اخرين في جعل قضيه
تامين النفط اولويه شعبيه وبحلول عام 1951
استسلم الشال الضغوط الشعبيه ووافق على
تصويت برلماني لتعيين مصدق رئيسا للوزراء
وفي اقل من اسبوع ثلاثه ايام الحقيقه يعني
من توليه السلطه اعلن مصدق تاميم صناعه
النفط الايرانيه واستحوذ على الاصول او
الشركات البريطانيه العامله في ايران
تاميم النفط الايراني كان ضربه كبيره جدا
لبريطانيا التي كانت تعاني بعد الحرب
العالميه الثانيه من ازمه اقتصاديه وضعتها
على حافه الافلاس بريطانيا لم تكن قلقه
فقط بسبب فقدانه عوائد النفط الايرانيه
لكن كان خفها الاكبر ان تكون فعلا مصدق
سابقه تقتدي بها دول اخرى ما يهدد مصالح
الامبراطوريه البريطانيه في الشرق الاوسط
وغيره
خصوصا بقى انه مصدق كان شخصيه تحظى بشعبيه
كبيره في ايران وخارجها على سبيل المثال
مجله تيم الامريكيه اخترته رجل العام في
عام
1951 هذه الشعبيه مع ميوله القوميه تمثل
بالنسبه للقوى الغربيه تهديد كبير
لمصالحهم والاقتصاديه والسياسيه في ايران
وفي الشرق الاوسط تذكروا عبد الناصر وكيف
امتد نفوذه الى كثير من دول العالم النامي
لم يكن الغرب مستعدا لعبد الناصر اخر
وبعوافر الاحترام للزعيم المصري جمال عبد
الناصر كان الدكتور مصدق كسياسي اكثر خبره
واكثر تعليما هو امر بالغ
الخطوره بالنسبه للدول الاستعماريه
وكان لابد من التخلص من الدكتور مصدق في
السنوات من 51 ل 53 كان الرئيس الامريكي
ترومان هو الذي يحكم الولايات المتحده
وكانت روم يعارض اي تدخل في الشان
الايراني من جانب بريطانيا مع بريطانيا
كانت تسعى للتدخل
للقضاء على مصدق منذ ان اتخذ قراره في
1951 لكن كانت رومن معارض ولم يكن يرى في
ذلك مصلحه امريكيه ودي قصه لطول شرحها لكن
بحلول يناير 1953 جاء ايضا للبيت الابيض
بافكار مختلفه ودعم خطه وينستن تشرشل رئيس
وزراء بريطانيا في التخلص من مصدق دوافع
ايزنهاور ما زالت محل مناقشه وخلاف
اذكركم انه لم يتم الكشف حتى هذه اللحظه
عن كل وثائق هذه الفتره ولكن اجمالا
بتنحصر دوافع ايضا في التخلص من مصدق في
اعتبارين اساسيين الاول التاكد من استمرار
السيطره على النفط الايراني من جانب
الشركات الغربيه ما يعني لايزنهاور ثلاثه
امور الامر الاول ان تستفيد الشركات
الامريكيه بشكل مباشر ثانيا الا ينهار
اقتصاد حليفه وبريطانيا
وثالثا والاهم الا يذهب هذا النفط
الايراني وهذا ياخذنا للاعتبار الثاني وهو
خوف امريكا من ان يكون الدكتور مصدق بيالا
للسوفيت وياخذ ايران في اتجاه الكتله
الشرقيه ودعم هذه المخاوف وجود حسبه توده
الشيوعي في ايران في هذه الفتره على
العموم اسفر تامر البلدين لعده شهور سرا
عن محاولتي انقلاب في خمسه ايام من 15 الى
19 اغسطس 1953
المحاوله الاولى وكان جوهرها ببساطه
انقلابا دستوريا فيه اخراج مصدق من السلطه
بامر ملكي بالمخالفه للدستور الدستور ما
كانش يسمح للشاه انه يصدر قرارا باقاله
رئيس حكومه ده امر لازم يقروا البرلمان
لكن ده كان تصور الامريكان وتبقى المساله
مساله خلاف وتقوم وحدات متامره من الجيش
على اجبار مصدق على الامتثال للامر الملكي
لكن هذه المحاوله فشلت والضابط او الضباط
اللي ذهبوا لابلاغ الدكتور مصدق بقرار
اقالته تم القبض عليهم
وعلى كل الاحوال في يعني وقائع التفاصيل
كثيره فشلت هذه المحاوله وفر الشاه خائفا
خارج البلاد وذهب بدايه الى بغداد لكن
بعدها باربعه ايام فقط نجحت المحاوله
الثانيه
وجوهرها كان اجبار مصدق ايضا على الخروج
من السلطه بالقوه لكن هذه المره باستخدام
الشبيحه والبلطجيه بدعم من كل القوى
الداخليه المتضرره من سياسه الدكتور
المصدق من ناحيه والقوى المستفيده من
استمرار النفوذ الغربي في ايران من ناحيه
الاخرى ودول طبعا موجودين في كل بلد صاحب
المحاوله الاولى والمحاوله الثانيه تطبيق
لادوات ما يعرف الان او مؤخرا بحروب الجيل
الرابع وكان اوضح اشكالها اثاره فوضى
عارمه وحمل التضليل مكثفه ضد الدكتور مصدق
وافكاره استخدم فيها الاعلام الذي اشتراه
الامريكان والبريطانيون بشكل واسع اقصد
الاعلام الايراني وقتها وتمت الاطاحه
بمصدق في 19 اغسطس 1953
ونقل بكل مؤيديه واعدم على سبيل المثال
وزير خارجيته حسين فاطمه
له قصه تصلح ماده لفيلم مثير ولكن هذه قصه
اخرى في 21 ديسمبر من نفس العام تمت
محاكمه الدكتور مصدق صوريا وحكم عليه
بالسجن لثلاثه سنه سنوات وكلمات مصدق لدى
سماعه النطق بالحكم ما زالت ترن في الاذان
هو الراجل كان مفوه ويحسن الخطابه
والتاثير في الجماهير لما سمعوا الحكم
عليه بثلاث سنوات سجنا في محكمه عسكريه
قال حكم هذه المحكمه زاد من امجاد
التاريخيه انا ممتن للغايه لانكم اذنتموني
لقد فهم الشعب الايراني الان وهذه الليله
حقا معنى واهميه الحكم الدستوري
بعد خروجه من السجن ظل قيد الاقامه
الجبريه في منزله في مدينه احمد اباد حتى
وفاته 5 مارس 1967 عن عمر يناهز حوالي 84
سنه ولم تعرف ايران بعده ابدا طريقها الى
الديمقراطيه او حتى شبه الديمقراطي نعود
للانقلاب بعد سقوط الدكتور مصدق تولى
الجنرال فضل الله زاهدي الموالي للغرب
رئاسه الوزراء وهو كان له دور كبير جدا في
محاولتي الانقلاب الاولى والثانيه وطبعا
عاد الشاه لايران وبدعم من امريكا
وبريطانيا اسس محمد رضا بهلوي حكما سلطويا
ل 25 عاما اخرى حتى اطاحت به الثوره
الايرانيه سنه 79 ملحوظه امريكا نفت
لسنوات طويله تورطها في الانقلاب واصدرت
وزاره الخارجيه الامريكيه لاول مره وثائق
تتعلق بهذه الفتره التاريخ من تاريخ ايران
يعني في عام 1989 لكن بعد حذف اي اشاره
لتورط السي اي ايه في الانقلاب في انقلاب
حكومه الدكتور مصدق تحت ضغوط الراي العام
الراي العام من النخب طبعا مش الراي العام
المواطن الامريكي العادي المواطن الامريكي
العادي غير معني بما حدث في فرنسا سنه 53
لكن تحت ضغوط النخب الامريكيه نشرت
الحكومه وثائق تشير الى تورطها في
الانقلاب لاول مره في سنه 2013 وفي يونيو
2017 افرج عن عدد ضخم من الوثائق الاضافيه
عن تفاصيل دور المخابرات الامريكيه
والبريطانيه في الانقلاب مع العلم ان
الكثير من برقيات وكاله المخابرات
الامريكيه وتقاريرها الاصليه في تلك
الفتره اختفت او دمرت او مازالت قيد
الكتمان من جانب السلطات الامريكيه
للتاخير الطويل في الكشف عن الو مع العلم
ان الولايات المتحده والدول الديمقراطيه
المماثله بتكشف عن وثائقها السريه بعد
مرور 30 35 سنه ما لم يمثل او ما لم تمثل
هذه الوثائق خطرا على الامن القومي
للولايات المتحده نقدر نستنتج مجموعه من
الاسباب منهم سبب دايما دائم يعني انه
اجهزه المخابرات في امريكا وخارجها بتهتم
دائما بحمايه مصادرها وعملائها مهما طال
الزمن ما لم تجبر على الكشف عن تفاصيل ما
قامت به تاريخيا
ثانيا التفاصيل ما حدث في 53 كان من شانه
ان يعقد العلاقات مع ايران
طبعا بدل انقلاب في وقتها نجاحا سهلا
وسريعا تخلص الامريكان والبريطانيون من
الدكتور مصدق اعادوا رجلهم اللي هو الشاه
الى ايران
اطمئنوا على مصالحهم في النفط الايراني
اطمئنوا ايضا الا تذهب ايران الى معسكر
السفليت كل هذا عظيم جدا بالنسبه لهم لكن
على المدى البعيد كانت توابع هذا الانقلاب
خطيره جدا على كل الصعود ونقدر نلخص خطوره
هذا الانقلاب في اربعه اعتبارات اساسيه
واحد ضرب هذا الانقلاب الديمقراطيه
الايرانيه ولم تشهد ايران منذ سقوط
الدكتور مصدق اي تطور في اتجاه الحكم
الديمقراطي
دمرت العلاقات بين امريكا وبين الشعب
الايراني قد لا يعلم الكثيرون ان العلاقات
بين امريكا وايران لعشرات السنوات قبل هذا
الانقلاب كانت علاقات ودوده جدا وكانت
الصوره الذهنيه لدى الايرانيين عن
الولايات المتحده باعتبارها قوه صاعده
تدعم الحريه وتدعم شعوب المستضعفه ولم يكن
هناك اي تعقيدات بين امريكا والايرانيين
مثل التعقيدات اللي شهرتها العلاقات
الايرانيه البريطانيه او العلاقات
الايرانيه الروسيه الى اخره فكانت علاقات
ممتازه جدا دمرت هذه العلاقات بعد هذا
الانقلاب ومش دمرت على مستوى الشعب العادي
لكن كمان اصبحت هناك قطيعه وعدم ثقه بين
الامريكان وبين النخب الايرانيه
شجع نجاح هذا الانقلاب السي اي ايه على
الانخراط الواسع في سياسات تغيير الانظمه
حول العالم والاهم هو ان هذا الانقلاب
معهد الطريق لقيام الثوره ثوره 1979 التي
غيرت كل شيء في الشرق الاوسط اذا حبيتوا
مزيد من التفاصيل
فسقوط مصدق ضرب فعلا مسيره الديمقراطيه
الايرانيه التي كانت تسير بوتيره جيده جدا
بالنسبه لدوله من دول العالم الثالث تحولت
ايران بعد سقوطه من ملكيه دستوريه الى
ملكيا متسلطه اسس الشاه الذي ادرك ان
وجوده مرتبط بالحفاظ على مصالح الغرب
نظاما مواليا تماما لامريكا وبريطانيا
وعزز علاقاته باسرائيل في المنطقه واصرف
في استخدام القمع ضد شعبه من خلال جهاز
مخابراته سيء السمعه سافاك لاسكاد كل صوت
معارض ادت سياساته في النهايه لاندلاع
ثوره
1979 والتي قادها وسيطر عليها ايه الله
الخميني اتاحه الثوره بحكم الشاه اسست
الجمهوريه الاسلاميه التي جعلت من ضرب
المصالح الغربيه والامريكيه هدفا اساسيا
لها تذكروا ان واحده من اولى تصرفات
الثوار الايرانيين اثناء الثوره كان
اقتحام السفاره الامريكيه
واحتلالها واحتجاز من فيها رهائن لمده 444
يوم هذه الازمه كانت البذره التي زرعت
كراهيه ايران في قلوب الكثير من الامريكان
اي امريكان الامريكان الذين تجاهلوا دورهم
في انقلاب 1953 وركزوا فقط على احتجاز
الرهائن باعتبارها عدوانا ايرانيا غير
مبرر على امريكا اي اننا اصبحنا امام
دولتين كل منهم يكره الاخر ولا يثق فيه
ولكن لم مختلفه امريكا ترى ان مشاكلها مع
ايران بدات باحتجاز الرهائن
1979 وايران ترى ان المشاكل بدات قبل ذلك
ب 25 سنه عندما تدخلت امريكا للاطاحه
بمصدق دون مبرر للعدوان على سياده ايران
ومقدراتها افتح قسم كبار هناك الان مصادر
امريكيه مختلفه بتقول انه اشخاص نافذين في
جهات امريكيه مختلفه عمدو الى عدم حل ازمه
الرهائن لاسباب تتعلق برغبه هذه الجهات في
اسقاط الرئيس جيمي كارتر وهذه قصه يطول
شرحها ثانيا وبعيد عن مصالح امريكا
وعلاقتها بايران قيام الجمهوريه الاسلاميه
اللي هو كان اهم نتائج الاطاحه بالدكتور
مصدق على الاطلاق كان نقطه تحول في تاريخ
الشرق الاوسط حدث مزلزل تخيل كيف كان يمكن
ان تكون منطقه الشرق الاوسط اذا لم تندلع
الثوره الايرانيه سنه
1979 كل شيء تغير لكن ما كان لهذه الثوره
ان تقوم على الارجح لولا الاطاحه بحكومه
الدكتور مصدق وتغيير مسار تاريخ وسياسه
ايران على النحو الذي جرى في اغسطس 1953
واخيرا شجع النجاح السريع للانقلاب على
مصدق وقتها السي اي ايه على تدبير
انقلابات اخرى حول العالم لان الانقلاب
على حكومه الدكتور مصدق كان اول تجربه
كبيره ربما سبقها تجارب محدوده لتغيير
نظام الحكم في دوله اجنبيه من جانب السي
اي ايه بعد هذا الانقلاب تورطت المخابرات
الامريكيه في محاولات كثيره لتغيير انظمه
الحكم في دراسه قدرت ان الولايات المتحده
السي اي ايه يعني
تورطت في 72 محاوله انقلاب اثناء الحرب
البارده فقط اي من 1947 حتى عام
1989 لكن قليل جدا من يجادل ان الاطاحه
بالدكتور مصدق كانت الاخطر اثرا على
الاطلاق في 72 محاوله
ملحوظه اخيره انخرط امريكا في سياسه تغيير
الانظمه لم يكن امرا تاريخيا مرتبط بالحرب
البارده وانتهى بانتهائها هذه السياسه ما
زالت قائمه واذا اردتم مثالا حديثا واضحا
فما عليكم الا ان تتابعوا دور امريكا في
الانقلاب على عمران خان والذي تجري فصوله
الان في باكستان امريكا زي ما قلت
لحضراتكم تورطت في عشرات محاولات الانقلاب
حول العالم لكن هناك حالات كانت صارخه جدا
لان هذه المحاولات تمت ضد سياسيين
انتخبوا بشكل ديمقراطي مثل حاله محمد مصدق
سنه 53 ومثل حاله عمران خان في 2022
و2023 ما يعني ان امريكا زعيمه العالم
الحر التي تدافع ليلا ونهارا امام
الكاميرات عن الديمقراطيه سرا مستعدا
للتخلص من سياسي ين تم انتخابهم بشكل
ديمقراطي فقط لانهم يقفون ضد المصالح
الامريكيه وهذه قصه تستحق ان نتوقف عندها
في حلقات مقبله باذن الله اشكركم والى
اللقاء